hey I'm Nick Kroll I'm here at BuzzFeed
and I'm here to read your thirst tweets
and I'm thirsty for them tweets my new
year's resolution is to make out with
Nick Kroll this is from December 2012 so
uh it worked I'm not gonna say who it is
but it works Nick Kroll is funniest but
hot as hell I don't know why they have
to be mutually exclusive yes I'm a girl
yes I find Nick Kroll more attractive
than Shawn Mendes we exist I don't
I definitely think Shawn Mendes is
hotter than me what if that was Camila
Cabello I want Nick Kroll's beard to me
can i watch this from 2015 that was when
my beard was in full effect and my beard
ended up penis person and then they ran
off together and all I was left with was
this scruff and they're very happy
together so what can I say Nick Kroll is
such a strange mix of beautiful sexy and
adorable
I wrote that tweet now I'm not saying
this is something I think about a lot
but Nick Kroll splitting his pants on
Jimmy Kimmel Live basically proves that
Gil faizon is thick that's M with a CC
yeah it's true I got a big ol drum purr
and I love it
I've been drinking and watching videos
of Nick Kroll for hours he's extra sexy
when he uses the hormone monster voice
keep drinking sweetheart something
that's so creepy about that like if you
don't know big mouth you just think I'm
a total creep or if you know big mouth
and I'm still hungry it's so damn cold
in my house but still number one on my
brain is how badly I want to kiss Nick
Kroll that's very flattering but also
like you should really get the heat
looked at in your house you deserve
warmth whether you make out with me or
not I want to make sweet love to Nick
Kroll I want to make sour love to you
then we could have some sweet and sour
sex like a hot asian soup Nick Kroll let
me suck your toes okay I'm here for it
I'm here for you I'm like Alison I'm
like thinking about my toes
- I have a fungal infection I don't so
we're good and even if I did maybe
that's a junior they're gonna want that
fungal infection Nichols my celebrity
crush and I don't care who knows I'm
honored one of my favorite things is
that someone once cited Nick Kroll as
their celeb crush because he keeps it
tight and now I will never ever mention
Nick Kroll without side barring that he
keeps it tight I genuinely don't know
what that means like I don't know if
it's physically like always keep I keep
it tight or like I just keep them like
I'm constantly clenched or I have a
tight circle of friends around me and I
would say all three are true so it seems
the sexual attraction of Nick Kroll
isn't going away and I have to say I'm
not mad about it either mine it would be
a bummer if you're like I used to be
attracted to Nick Kroll and now I'm not
help I want to make out with John
Mulaney and Nick Kroll at the same time
this was written by Mike Birbiglia Mike
you can just tell us this in person you
don't have to do it Twitter I've decided
Nick Kroll a dirty hot in a way I could
really get behind or rather he could
really get behind me
I like that wordplay that's sweet dirty
hot like a guy who wears like a big like
shearling jacket indoors that kind of
dirty huh Nick Kroll is attractive but
Nick Kroll in an apron hits differently
at heart I'm a homemaker and I think
that's what people are attracted to Nick
Kroll got thick lips and thick hips
that's the thick with two C's of course
first time I've heard of thick hips but
I'll take it I think I'm gonna become a
fashion ovah model you measured all of a
sudden if that was my vibe on Instagram
in like yoga pants in like a weird tube
top promoting tummy tea
why does Nick Kroll lick his lips all
the time when he could lick mine I don't
have access to your lips and I'm not
insecure about your lips being dry
watching the Kroll show I honestly can't
tell who is more attractive Nick Kroll
dressed as a woman or Jenny slate I'm
assuming this is in reference to me and
Jenny in publicity and I'll be honest
like yeah when I'm dressed as Liz Omaha
does Nick Kroll should host the hashtag
Oscars host and I'm not just being a
kiss-ass because I think he's hot as
hell I think he'd do great
that's actually very nice because you
know most of the time I get the gigs I
get because of how attractive I am and
not because of any of my comedic
abilities so this means the world to me
unfortunately did not work they so
didn't want me and or me and John to
host the Oscars they have gone without a
host that's how much they didn't want us
to host the Oscars watching oh hello on
Broadway Nick Kroll and John Mulaney so
sexy to me in old man costumes thank you
this was clearly not written but by my
girlfriend who does not find me I get it
like you don't want to go to bed with
someone who during the day looks like an
old man baby you know but this person
does and God you know god bless I have a
lot of Dreams where I make out with Nick
Kroll and they're always a little weird
but my parents walking in on us making
out is by far the weirdest and this is a
peek into my psyche folks it really is I
only make out with people when their
parents can walk in the room which makes
it hard when you make out with someone
who have like old parents because then
they're like you have to like figure out
a way to make out in their hospital and
the look of shock and excitement on that
hospital bed ridden old parents face is
what turns me on the most Nick Kroll can
suck my kenny day honestly thank you I
really appreciate that because like some
people want to suck you they only want
you to suck there certain days so the
idea that this person wanted me to suck
there any day leaving that option open
for me and what works with my schedule
I'm very grateful
oMG Nick Kroll thank you very cool is so
funny this guy's so funny I want to him
which is odd so hilarious it gets me
horny little smiley face lol this this
tweet is from 2011 so I guess I missed
the boat on that one that was the one
person that watched thank you very cool
my special on Comedy Central hey Hulu
how many episodes of Kroll show do I
need to watch before I have a weird
sexual thing for Nick Kroll
oh just one I think this person knew the
answer to this question before they
wrote this Nick Kroll let's go smoke a
bowl and then you can suck my mole maybe
lick my hole
not only is this person a talented
rhymer but they know what they want Nick
Kroll is so hot to me why can't I be 35
and in the industry so I can hit on him
35 is an appropriate age for me to date
but in the industry I'm like whoa whoa
whoa are you in the industry you're not
then you can't hit on me I would let
Nick Kroll eat my app thank you before
8:00 anyone's asked and get their
consent
hey kids out there if you're trying to
eat ass make sure to find out if that
person wants you to get that ass
whenever I look at Nick Kroll my monkey
brain goes horny cavemen like you know
that man would suck hog like a madman
but I like that it's my monkey brain
goes horny caveman so it's the evolution
where the monkey is becoming the man and
that's when this person is like I wanted
to call it suck that Nick Kroll says
nothing and then me this person says me
we've we've we've we've me I mean I'm
gonna be honest I would like a little
more say in the matter you're taking
away my voice and I think for a great
sexual relationship there needs to be
some back-and-forth Nick Kroll makes my
Buzzi tingle yeah I've heard that for
[ __ ] I know I've cuz I've watched a few
of these videos a couple of the dudes
come in and they're like bussy what's a
bussy and I'm like oh no it's a [ __ ]
and I know what it is the ladybug on big
mouth loves talking about [ __ ] in fact
there are people with the ladybug tattoo
and it says Buzzi on it the idea that
someone would put that on their skin
permanently makes my [ __ ] tingle I'm
Nick Kroll and this has been thirst
tweets and boy have they been thirsty
you can watch me in Olympic dreams on
demand and theaters right now
[Music]